so in all of our videos on special
relativity so far we've had this little
thought experiment where i'm floating in
space and right at time equals zero a
friend passes by in her spaceship she's
traveling in the positive x direction
velocity is equal to v
and we draw space-time diagrams for both
of us first i draw my space-time diagram
in white and then i overlay her
space-time diagram and the angle that is
formed between the time axes and the
position axes right over there that's
going to be dictated by how fast v is
how fast she is actually traveling and
we give the space-time diagram from her
frame of reference we see with the
little primes right over there now one
thing that you might have been thinking
about throughout this entire series was
well if i perceive her traveling with a
velocity of v in the positive x
direction if we took her point of view
and that's what i have right over here
if she views herself as just floating in
space what she will see me as right at
time equals zero actually i'd say right
at t prime is equal to zero we're saying
that t prime and x prime t prime and t
equals zero are coinciding
right at that moment she will see me fly
by at negative v going in the pod in the
negative x direction once again there's
no there's no absolute frame of
reference these frames of reference are
all absolute
these frames of reference are all
relative and so you could imagine what
would look like is if we drew her
space-time diagram where her ct prime
axis and x-prime axes that they are
perpendicular to each other and then
based on that my space-time diagram
would be at an angle and it's at an
angle like this you can kind of see the
positive ct axis is in the second
quadrant here because i'm traveling with
the velocity of negative e but these
angles are going to be the same this is
going to be alpha and that is going to
be let me let me write this is going to
be
alpha and this is going to be and this
right over here is going to be alpha
now what i want to do in this video is
use this symmetry use these these two
ideas to give us a derivation of the
lawrence transformation or the lawrence
transformations and the way we might
start and this is actually a reasonable
way that the lawrence transformations
were stumbled upon is to say all right
we could start with the galilean
transformation where we could say
all right the galilean transformation
would be x prime
is equal to
is going to be equal to
x
minus
v times t
v
times t
now we already know that if you just use
the galilean transformation then the
speed of light would not be absolute it
would not be the same in every frame of
reference and so we had to let go of the
constraints that time and space are
absolute and so there's going to be some
type of scaling factor involved and so
we can call that scaling factor gamma
so we could say all right let's just
let's just postulate that there's going
to if we that x prime if we assume the
speed of light is absolute is going to
be some scaling factor gamma times x
minus vt
well you can make the same argument the
other way around if you view if you view
it from her frame of reference and
you're trying to translate into my
coordinates you could say well
x
instead of just using the galleon
transformation that x
is going to be equal to
x is going to be equal to
x
prime and now instead of a v we have a
negative v right so if you subtract a
negative e in fact let me just write it
that way x minus
negative v
times t prime that would be the galilean
transformation
but whatever scaling factor we used here
these are there's a symmetry here i
shouldn't have to use a different
scaling factor if i assume a different
uh kind of
if i'm in a different frame of reference
so
if we assume the absoluteness of the
speed of light we're going to have some
other scaling factor just like that or
we could rewrite this as
as x
let's do that same color
we could rewrite it as x
is equal to
this scaling factor i'm really having
trouble changing colors today
it's going to be equal to that scaling
factor times
times
x prime subtract a negative plus
v t prime and if you ignore the scaling
factor right over here this is the
galilean transformation from the primed
frame of reference to the non-primed
frame of reference so an interesting
thing is well what is this scaling
factor how do we figure out what that
scaling factor is going to be
and so we can do a little bit of
interesting algebra here what we could
do is actually let me just write what i
just wrote let me write it right below
here so
we could say that
x again changing colors is difficult we
could write that x is equal to
our scaling factor
gamma
times
x prime
times x prime
plus v
t
prime
and now what i'm going to do in order to
to have myself an equation that involves
all of the interesting variables i'm
going to multiply both sides of this
equation by i guess i could i one way to
think about it i'm going to multiply
both sides of this top equation by x so
if i multiply the left hand side by x
i'm going to have
x
times x prime
x times x prime and then the right hand
side of the equation
i can multiply by x but x is the same
thing i'm saying it's the same thing as
gamma times all of this business so i'm
just going to multiply the left-hand
sides of the equation and i'm going to
multiply the right-hand sides of the
equation so if i multiply the right-hand
sides of the equation i am going to get
gamma squared
times and i'm going to have a big
expression here
and so just really
applying the distributive property twice
x times x prime
x
times
x prime and then x
times positive vt
so
so whoops that prime doesn't look like a
prime x times x prime
plus
x times positive vt
x times
actually positive vt prime i should say
got to be careful here x times positive
v t prime
and then i have negative v t times x
prime
so it's going to be
negative v t
times x prime
times x prime and then finally i'll have
negative vt times positive vt prime so
that's going to be i could write that as
negative
let's write that as vt squared
v
sorry negative v squared
and actually let me delete this
this parentheses i don't want to force
myself to squeeze for no reason
so i'm going to have negative v times v
so that's negative v squared
times
times t
times t prime
times
t
prime and now let me place my
parentheses
so how can i use all of this craziness
here to actually solve for gamma
and here we're going to go back to one
of the fundamentals postulates one of
the assumptions of special relativity
and that's the speed of light is
absolute you're going to measure it to
be the same in any frame of reference
and to think about that let's imagine an
event that is connected with the origin
with a light beam so let's say right at
time and t prime is equal to zero
i were to shoot my flashlight and let's
say it hits something
at some point
right so
there we look at some event right over
there and they're connected by a light
beam by photon so let me connect them
so let me
connect them
and so if you say once again this could
be me turning on my flashlight and the
photon at some future at some forward
distance and some forward time it could
just be at some position or maybe it
hits something it triggers some type of
reaction who knows what it does but
we're going to talk about this event
right over there that events in my frame
of reference its coordinates are going
to be x
and ct
and since we know the the speed of light
is absolute and the way that we've set
up these diagrams the any any path of
light is always going to be at a 45
degree or a negative 45 degree angle we
know that x is going to be equal to ct
x is going to be equal to ct
for this particular case i could draw it
on this
i could draw it on this diagram as well
if i'd like
just to show that i can so let me draw
that
so
it would look like this
and
we would once again have x equaling ct
how would you read that
well to get the x coordinate you go
parallel to the c t axis
so that would be the x coordinate on
this diagram and then the ct coordinate
you go parallel to the x axis so just
like that but once again x is going to
be equal to ct
and similarly because the speed of light
is going to be absolute in any frame of
reference
if we look at x prime
x prime
is going to be the same is going to need
to be equal to ct prime
c t prime if we look at over here
x prime
x prime is going to be equal to c t
prime once again because light this is
going to be at a 45 degree angle so x
prime is equal to c
t prime they're connected by light
events so if you take your change in x
divided by change of time is going to be
the speed of light so what we can do is
use this information for this particular
event if if gamma is going to be true
for all transformations it definitely
should be true for this particular event
i can use this i can use this
information to substitute back in and
then solve for gamma and that's exactly
what i'm going to do in the next video
although i encourage you to try it on
your own before you watch the next video